les secours en action hier soit quelques
instants après la collision deux
personnes viennent de perdre la vie sur
ce passage à niveau réputé accidentogène
depuis des années sur place les élus
locaux semblent excédés
ça fait 50 ans qu'on entend parler du
contournement
là on est dans une phase active il a été
reconnu comme étant un des passages à
niveau les plus dangereux de france le
onzième classe et et on devrait
faire maintenant ans accélérer le
dossier j'ai envie de lancer à ce soir
un message très simple à l'état il n'ya
plus à tergiverser
il faut désormais que le contour de bord
du passage à niveau de georges devienne
une vraie réalité une fois les barrières
abaissées
il ne s'écoule que quelques courtes
secondes avant le passage du train se
retrouver coincé au milieu est un piège
mortel
c'est aussi une véritable source
d'angoissé pour les automobilistes qui
passent ici régulièrement
il faut trouver une solution parce que
ça peut plus durer formulation énorme le
matin tout le monde se tout le monde est
au même moment pour aller travailler ça
va passer c'est vrai que ça manque de
visibilité
c'est une zone on va dire accidentogènes
et je pense que oui il ya certainement
quelque chose à faire des aménagements
pourtant été opérées ces dernières
années un feu tricolore
une signalisation spécifique des
ralentisseurs et des radars pour
certains c'est surtout le comportement
des conducteurs qui pose problème c'est
pas de passage à niveau qui est
dangereux c'est les gens parce que les
gens ils passent entre les barrières
j'ai vu x e accidents depuis on dit le
plus dangereux de france n'est pas plus
dangereux qu'un autre c'est les gens qui
sont dangereuses après les déclarations
des autorités
ici chacun attend désormais des actes
pour mettre un terme à ce point noir de
la nationale 77